[Music]  four seconds of bass that's all Selena  Gomez is teasing us with when it comes  to new music the singer will drop her  mysterious new single on May 18 and  here's what we know about it I've been  in the studio letting it sit for a  minute the song is called the bad liar  and the lyrics Selena's it shared so far  suggest it's about a crush possibly her  boyfriend the weekend you know it's a  totally different style of music so whoa  trying not to think about you trying to  play a coy trying to distract myself  she's also giving us this image laying  in what looks to be a hospital bed yeah  confusing can you tease what's coming up  for your own album I don't know I think  I think people are gonna be a little  surprised I'm excited for what's coming  so what does it all mean well here's  what Selena told et about what might be  inspiring her just last month everything  you know my personal life and my family  and friends I'm just a really happy  place I'm good  you